hello and welcome to this video playing
MJ sharaf another bingo off what do we
get no you always make this kind of huh
when they play this kind of line against
interesting opening of course that's not
bad for white just not particularly
interesting but ok I got a reversed
towers here why it is a tempo up wonder
on the Tosh so what is he going to play
like I'm going to take a spawns
I wonder its outset work chief c4 unite
a force normal in there in the colors
reverse position but it looks to be a TM
[Music]
yeah let's just let's play some
normal-looking moves reasonably quickly
and not like in the game before ever
spend 11 and a half minutes in the
opening and don't see the simple
reputation of this bad play of the
opponent some quick moves and then see
what happens
yeah my night is a little bit offside
that could be a problem but I've won the
center porn he can take his seven but it
shouldn't be all that great beat was
hanging as well i rather expect rook to
e1 and move like that but that night
night c4 looks okay
okay and 96 maybe that's what what he
wants to do mmm that's the point I don't
like to take on on d4 of it night coming
to c 6 is an issue really okay rook c8
look see eight maybe yeah but II I can
take you forward that's what I thought
at least why do you have something
better
let's it can also go night shift forward
okay my original idea was to take even
though it's not quite clear if this
makes me much it's really not clear it's
got this b5 move
and b5 looked quite irritating I have
the same
Queen B seven and then move the night
now we place it when I Sevendust Elaine
[Music]
great wow what a bad game I completely
misplayed this 97 Bishop e3 probably
[Music]
yeah but after Scott should be two
coming up I mean I think he could have
done much worse to my position could if
could could be could be could be worse
it is dangerous for me without any
question but I think he had even more
problematic things
I don't don't see anything super
threatening King g7 knocking f7 should
keep things reasonably intact I also can
take the bishop here it's something that
I should time morning keep in mind yeah
like here why can I not take this check
I can take this check check
and now here and no it is covered check
just completely the wide open position
looks you one coming I have no
coordination here
something that a computer will win
easily but for human it's not so easy
[Music]
we're taking the rook now also no time
check the energy drink me okay one chest
fever check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check white forfeits on time Wow
yeah just a weird game from start to
finish really yeah so I don't know I
mean Greg grabbing this year was
certainly correct but the whole
situation is not easy am Quincy seven
however have 8x h2 and c5 yeah this is
this is quite strong actually it also
prepared this didn't see this night be
seven I had never thought about 97 a
yearly as a decent position and he could
have improved yeah I think b5 here I can
already take B 5 which I did not see
he's giving up here much material a lot
of material and it's really not enough
yeah the jacket a check check yeah I
prolly I could have gone here and keep
the keep the materia write as much check
like here here everything is covered and
the night is blocking all kinds of
chicks yeah this would have been much
better and much easier chat lane after
the e6 phone gets lost this is not so
easy to play 18 seconds I actually he
blundered the Queen and my god
yeah it was a long day but still check
and here woo k1d could play and chest
that he loved their poor okay thanks for
watching